it's such a shame because
i don't think that drake
needs a ghost writer i think it was
almost like a convenience thing it was
just like okay we'll get what do you
think i think he needs a ghostwriter
because
when you rap you have a certain style
and so in order to get a new style
somebody has to introduce you to the
style so it wasn't bars
it was different stuff
yeah i got to change up my floating
fresh yeah when you did that uh
episode with dj academics and he was
like drake's brilliant because he
crossed over because he's he's did
something in spanish with bad bunny and
then he markets to everybody yeah like
he's switching up his style to march to
everybody but so so but that was just
one person style i guess you're saying
and then maybe other people i guess he
was inspired by but you can be inspired
by people without like literally just
saying hey you work for me put it
together but but i think drake got a
certain level and then brought on those
writers
it's like kevin hart that's like kevin
hart exactly at such a level now where
he's moving a million miles an hour
where it's like people are like oh you
know kevin has writers on it i don't
give a [ __ ] he did all the work yeah
yeah he's a level i assumed it was a
scalability thing yeah it's like i need
to drink
every year yeah exactly that's the same
about kanye
we kind of used to do well he had like
maybe one or two writers and now it's
like he has like 20 people on one song
well i don't care about kanye's bars
like i don't care if he writes him or
anybody else writes him because i look
at kanye as the producer yeah like he's
just he's he's putting together this
orchestra writer director like tarantino
yeah he's tarantino that's a great well
i guess tarantino right but i'm sure
tarantino's guys that like [ __ ] work
with him and like hell like yeah okay so
but the bummer about the drake thing is
like i don't know for whatever reason
maybe i'm like
biased but i just think like bar for bar
he could take down pretty much whoever i
really do believe that about drake and
we're gonna get roasted for this but i'm
with you i can i guess
i think drake doesn't miss like i'm
never like like like connie's last like
really two albums i wasn't like foaming
out the mouth for it like drake i can't
wait yeah we're saying two different
things like slappers yes
i'm here for slapping no okay
for bar like there's so many people who
are lyrically clear
push the t's button both of them
love it but like but uh what i mean by
barf i'm talking about bar for bar from
the people that are even in the convo
i'm not talking about like the you're a
super rap fan and like sound cloud guys
on the come up i'm not trying to hear
that crazy like it's like ski master
not kanye it's drake j kendrick i guess
cole yeah but if we were talking to
lyrics like you can even put eminem in
that discussion because like em just
only cares about lyrics doesn't care
about slappers so it's like his [ __ ]
verses are technical as [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah okay so are you a hip-hop head
yeah yeah yeah
yeah his favorite rapper is a little
baby
you're going to stop it favorite
single [ __ ] lyrics
were you mad when we got canceled for
the gay stuff
that's crazy right
so then what do we think happens you
think drake beats uh kanye absolutely
really
what do you mean define beat like when
if they yeah sells more uh
better first week numbers that's what
it's going to be looking at but you know
it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be way
less this is actually interesting
even if drake beats kanye or kanye beats
drake
they're both
gonna have much higher numbers because
people are gonna listen to both yeah
compare
they'll both do way better they're
multipliers every kanye fan gonna listen
that drake [ __ ] and be like yeah see
that's ass yeah and every drake fans can
listen to kanye should be like nah
that's ass drake got him my thing is
though why do they have beef do we know
like why why where's the beef what is
the beef is it because he hooked up with
[ __ ] kim kardashian's mom it's
calabasas it's like it's oh yeah we in
their town bro we might have to pull up
and just connie's office right up there
okay we're pulling up but yeah it's a
little bit ego it's also um
the fact that pusher came at drake and
pushes with kanye like that and he's
like
they drake says drake says like oh
he shared the information about his son
with kanye
yeah yeah
but yeah it's just ego [ __ ] yeah like
you want to be top dog and i understand
that's into it he's also in a manic
episode right like we acknowledge but my
thing is why is white right
drake wants to be top dog yeah but why
is drake going after push t right he
lost like he lost the rap battle even
though i was i'm upset yeah but he's
crushed he's petty as [ __ ] yeah drake is
the most petty [ __ ] like he
still does sneak disses to like people
he's killed i'm here and i'm hello yeah
i'm here someone's saying he will sneak
this a dude from a city that people only
in that city know i love it
love it oh yeah drake can do no wrong
but that's the thing why are you such a
big drake stan i don't know man i love
him yeah he doesn't miss him one bad
song no like his dominance in like i
almost look at hip hop the same way like
i look at like tech where it's like it's
really easy for [ __ ] to change up like
you could be the head of the tech game
and then a new piece of technology comes
out and then you are obsolete yeah and
the hip hop game is the same way like
you could be the number one [ __ ] dog
and then next year a new style comes out
and you just can't ride with that stuff
that's what j cole said like his dis
song was like about little pump and all
those guys there's no longevity here
yeah you guys are doing yeah you really
have talent yeah yeah yeah it's not
going to be around man so enjoy it while
it's here yeah i don't know it's just
impressive what drake has done man like
you